how many of you guys have no idea who I
am nice
that's the best I love it I don't think
a lot of you guys get enough respect for
what you do all right is the big day I'm
giving my keynote here in Dallas
I spoke to too many people for too long
yesterday and burned my throat out
coughing a little bit so I'm not gonna
be vlogging much today gonna save my
voice try to hurt some people so I
apologize for not having a lot of
footage but good news here comes the
keynote for you
[Music]
do you believe I'm sorry I'm sorry
do you believe ladies and gentlemen our
keynote speaker my good friend Evan
Carmichael thank you thank you guys
quickly I wanna i want to thank jeremy
his wife owen the whole team here it's a
lot of work to put this together it's
their second year in and i did a bang-up
job hopefully you guys learned a lot
just give a quick round of applause for
Jeremy and his team hopefully we'll see
you again next year
be even bigger and better for context
how many of you guys have no idea who I
am
nice that's the best I love it okay I
want to tailor this to help you guys out
in the best way possible a quick poll
how many guys work at brains big
companies okay creators okay and then
agencies got it
so mix anything else okay I want to give
you a little bit of context on me and
then get into it
I have 1.5 million subscribers on my
youtube channel we do three videos a day
we've done 6000 uploads on the channel
5,000 and the public I might be hard
working but I'm not super talented
I developed the talent by working hard
and making lots of videos we had
hundreds of comments every day on the
channel I respond
me and my team respond to every single
one of them and I work with tons of
brands we work with Microsoft American
Express sage mostly in the
Entrepreneurship space so I feel the
pain from all the year worlds I want to
talk about respect and responsibility I
don't think a lot of you guys get enough
respect for what you do
all of you like for the brand's I feel
your pain for the people who are here
who are trying to sell video trying to
sell social up the ladder you don't get
enough respect you don't get the
resources you don't get the credibility
you're asked to prove metrics that
nobody else has to prove video is not
just the future it's the present
but most big companies don't see that if
they actually gave respect your CMO
would be here right now
your CEO would be here right now but
they're not and you are and and I want
to recognize that you guys are champions
and are awesome for creators it's the
same thing with respect you guys bring
an insane amount of value to the brands
that you do work with but you don't get
paid enough for it you're giving a lot
of attention away you're helping this
company way more than anything else
they're spending on but you're not
getting paid enough and so I want us to
celebrate a little bit of how awesome we
are and feel walking out this conference
like we have our head up high and we're
going to start creating more respect for
ourselves we're pioneers and when you're
pioneer you have to eat a lot of the
arrows in your back how do you know who
the Pioneers are the balloons are the
arrows in their back if you want to be
innovative if you want to be different
if you want to send out you want to
shake the status quo there's a lot of
people who want to protect that status
quo and that creates problems for
innovators like us so I see us as a tree
we're trees this is the analogy like use
we're trees what does a tree do a tree
breathes in poison carbon dioxide a
breeze in poison carbon dioxide eats it
grows from it and then spits out
positivity oxygen if you want to be an
innovator if you want to be a leader
then you need to accept that you are a
tree that's it's gonna be tons of poison
around you and it's your job to eat it
grow from it and spit out positivity
it's your responsibility to do it
there's a million reasons why you have
difficulties I'm empathetic I understand
from brands and creators there's a
million reasons why it's difficult for
you to get to where you want to go I
want to change this conversation to stop
focusing on the millions of legit
reasons why you can't win and focus in
on the four five six where you can
it's changing the mindset from how am I
ever gonna get there - how am I ever
gonna get there same words different
mindset and that's what I hope you guys
walk away not just from my presentation
but the whole event like this has to
mean something this has to matter we've
all given up our time I've given up time
with my wife my son my team building my
business - when I'm doing at home and I
know all of you have - and it means zero
if you don't go home and actually do
something that's the greatest gift that
the speaker's want for you and I know
you want for yourself but what happens
too often is you come to a conference
you have a whole notebook full of ideas
and you take no action if you've learned
anything from any of the speakers today
go home and do something about it
an imperfect plan that is executed well
is way better than the perfect plan
where you did zero on it thanks Brian
[Laughter]
so more I'm gonna give you more tactics
today we're gonna dive into it but
whether you take one thing for me or one
thing from Brian or Nick or Tim or
Darrell anybody else like you got to go
home and do something about it because I
don't want to see you here next year
asking the same questions and be in the
same spot that you are right now and
that starts by going home tonight and
doing something so it's my little rant
let's get into some content I'm gonna
talk about strategy content leverage we
can go through each one quickly and then
I want to get to some questions from you
guys
because I want to bring as much value as
possible strategy it starts with being
proud of your work this is if you have
one filter to look through all of your
content it has to be this be proud of
your work would you subscribe to your
own channel and unfortunately for a lot
of you the answer is no especially on
the brand side you wouldn't subscribe to
your own channel you wouldn't share any
of these videos with your mom you're not
part of your own work that's a problem
not just from a marketing positioning
success but for you like for your own
mental health you're going out and doing
work every day
on something that you are not proud of
what you've created this needs to be the
filter through which you make your
decisions I am proud of every piece of
content that we put out and on the
creator side we often feel forced to
chase trends and do slime videos and do
something just a game the algorithm and
if you do that for too long you're not
proud of what you're gonna lose you have
to do work that you're proud of anybody
here from Bank of America one person all
right I have a love-hate relationship
with Bank of America Bank the Bank of
America founder is is my favorite
entrepreneur of all time AP Giannini is
my favorite entrepreneur of all time
he's the man who bet on Walt Disney when
everybody thought he was stupid he gave
people a loan based off of a handshake
and a look in their eye if you can
imagine that from a banker and I'm just
I love the Maine so much that I'm
sometimes disappointed in how the brain
has evolved so I'm gonna use them a
couple times in my examples here this is
the Bank of America YouTube channel
they have 82,000 subscribers they get
that just because their Bank of America
and the creators here like what would I
do for 82,000 subscribers I would I
would not eat for a week to get eighty
two thousand subscribers and you just
get it automatically being Bank of
America or being a big brand so just you
play with what you've got
right don't focus on what you don't have
you focus on what you can do with what
you do have these guys have eighty two
thousand subscribers these are the
videos that came up these are recent
videos so 82,000 subs we got videos 600
views 500 views 200 views 193 views that
one on the right 193 views at the top
how to grow your Bank of America
business advantage something 50%
approval that means they got as much
thumbs up as thumbs downs they spent a
lot of money on these videos these
videos are no joke right they're
professional actors professional crew
professional motion graphics a lot of
money spent on these videos that are not
helpful you got a hundred and ninety
three views on that video and half the
people disliked it
but this is there's no way the Bank of
America team who made this are happy
with this like there's no way that you
can say I'm proud of this work and this
isn't just picking a Bank of America I
just picked a random one because I love
Bank of America's story and I want to
see them get better but this is almost
any brand what brand do you love going
and watch their YouTube channel and same
thing for the brains like would you
subscribe to this would you share any
videos with your parents no you need to
be proud of the work that you're doing
it's the only way you win always and
forever - this gets controversial reply
to every comment you have to reply to
every comment for brains it's easy
because nobody's commenting on your
videos well you've got four comments
like just respond it's not difficult
just it doesn't happen so somebody's
coming you want engagement you want you
say you want engagement you want traffic
you want people to care you want to
reach
but then somebody's come in and say
thank you so much for this video and
what do you do you ignore them right
it's like we don't want to hear from you
on the creator side all the small
creators like yeah of course I respond
to every comment and I remember like
when I was getting started the very few
first comments I get a comment like
every four or five videos like yeah I
got a comment somebody likes it and I'd
be like I get the notifications like
immediately reply to that person but I
think as you build up and grow most
people get this wrong I think almost
every youtuber gets this wrong what's
the best practice for responding to
comments once you have a channel of a
certain size to spend 30 minutes after
video went live in the comments and it
ignore everything else because it
becomes an avalanche like I get hundreds
of comments on my videos every day if I
was to sit in front of the computer and
respond the comments all day long I
couldn't do this but what's the answer
you build a team put on your CEO hat
when when you reply to somebody's
comment there's 7 times more likely to
subscribe to your channel
you want subscribers they're sitting
there right in your comments section
reply show some love so I hired team and
I think people say well that's crazy
have to do it all yourself no you don't
why do you do all yourself if I had a
little flower stand on the side of a
street and I'm selling flowers and I'm
cutting them and I'm buying them and I'm
selling them I I deal with every single
customer myself great but if I want to
have a flower shop I want to expand I
want one flower shop two flower shops I
can't deal with every customer that
comes in the door right I need to hire
staff this is how you build any business
forever in all time as you scale you
need a team but for some weird reason
the default strategy and YouTube line
has been let's just respond to some
people for half an hour and then ignore
everybody else for some reason that's
the best practice I think it's wrong I
think people are misguided and I want
you guys to win like let everybody else
do that you guys go and win respond to
every comment build a team to respond to
the comments they filter out the ones
that you might need to see I only want
to see the negative my team responds to
all the good ones thank you so much for
the video most of the comments aren't
super enlightening thank you so much I
really enjoyed this video
great just give them a little bit of
love some recognition you'll be the only
channel almost that does it but then the
ones that are the problems like hey Evan
you suck yeah I want to see that one
send that one to me all right I want to
know why I suck because I want to get
better that's the only way to improve so
you want to spawned every comment oh I
have it I have a I have a little prop I
have a prop that I forgot to take it did
I want to show you guys because this is
a simple process that every business
understands but for whatever reason in
YouTube Blaine we don't think about our
business as a business so you don't grow
I got this under my door from the
Gaylord Texan you guys like the Gaylord
Texan join your rooms pretty sick I
walked in and like they really do things
big in Texas this is my first time here
and like this place is ridiculous so I'm
checking in and the guys like hey are
you a youtuber because there's a big
YouTube
event here like yeah I have a youtube
channel like okay what's your name Evan
Carmichael and that's fine didn't I
didn't say that I was speaking or
anything they then make this note slip
under my door and it says mr. Carmichael
thank you so much for staying with us we
looked up your YouTube account you're a
star it was an honor meeting you how
long did that take to do they spent a
minute going to my YouTube channel
typing and Evan Carmichael finding it
they spent a minute writing this and
they spent two and a half minutes
sending somebody up to find my room
inside another door so for four and a
half minutes I feel love for the Gaylord
Texan and now they're being broadcast
here as a best-case scenario best
practice how long does it take you to
respond to a youtube comment less than
four and a half minutes like the service
industry gets it the YouTube industry
doesn't so you guys can be the leaders
you have to build a business respond to
every comment it's not the founder of
the Gaylord Texan or the CEO or the
hotel manager sending me this card it
comes from the front desk and this means
something to me that I wanted to bring
it out of my bag save it and share with
you guys let me give you an example of
what not to do thank you for my ok or
you could do this let's disable comments
on our video let's have a big party and
make content and then close the door
like we don't even want to hear from you
we're not just going to ignore you we
say no we don't even want to hear from
you like if this is going to be your
approach then don't don't create content
like this is why you are losing this is
just a money pit for you and I get it
it's either you don't have the time or
resources which is a mindset issue but
you're still not going to get that many
comments anyway because it's not that
many views or you're worried about the
haters you worried about the negativity
right for brains you're worried about
people coming in leaving rage comments
on your videos I think those are great I
think how you respond to a rage comment
says a lot about your brand and I don't
think that you necessarily gonna turn
around those haters with a nice comment
reply although you might but how you
respond to a hater speaks volumes to
everybody
who's watching the comments if somebody
is raging on you and being unreasonable
and you leave an understanding
empathetic sweet comment that's gonna
mean a lot to everybody else who's gonna
take your side and build brand loyalty
you've been a thought leader on how to
deal with negativity online don't do
this have a face this is the hardest one
for brands have a face you need to face
for the brand this is this is where
creators win as entrepreneurs this is
where you win you want to take on big
companies you want to be number one you
want to siphon their audience this is it
it's your story your face people don't
connect to a logo I want to know the
person who's behind this brand and
ideally it's the founder sometimes it's
easy sometimes you're a one-woman show
so you are the founder that's easy for
big companies though often the founders
dead EP Giannini is gone he's not around
anymore we can't do it so who's next CEO
great most CEOs are too afraid to come
on and make videos those CEOs are gonna
lose every CEO is gonna have a vlog it's
gonna happen every CEO is going to have
a vlog it's going to be how you market
telling your story and the CEOs now
don't have to do it anybody who's in a
CEO position now and they've got you
know five years left okay they'll be
fine
rome wasn't built in a day but rome also
didn't crumble in a day and these brains
are crumbling for these reasons I have
no business existing the content that I
have what I'm doing on YouTube I should
not exist CNN should be doing what I'm
doing
Bank of America should be doing what I'm
doing I'm pulling in hundreds of
millions of views from big companies
when they should be coming in and
destroying me and they're better they
have better talent they have way more
resources they have great equipment they
got teams of people I shouldn't be
winning for the brands in here your
brain is eroding you are becoming
irrelevant you need to have a face
now ideal is a CEO founder CEO but if
it's not don't let that stop you why
can't it be you
instead of focusing on the millions of
reasons why you won't win folks in the
for how you why can't it be you all I
want is somebody who cares all I want
are these two people I can't read their
names Kramer and Shaw much be Kramer and
Shaw much
sorry Shaw much probably butchered that
but it's written in huge marker that
could be you I was working with
Microsoft Canada and I'm from Toronto
and the VP of small business for
Microsoft Canada came at an event and
like he's so far away from the CEO
there's so many there's a ons of levels
from him to the CEO and he comes on he
does a speech and he's talking about how
he loves entrepreneurs he grew up the
son of entrepreneurs his parents were an
entrepreneur he worked at their shop he
worked with them every day he loves
entrepreneurs he didn't want to become
an entrepreneur but he loves supporting
them because every time he works with an
entrepreneur it's like he's helping his
parents and that makes him feel really
good and he wants to use it through
Microsoft because he wants people to
focus on their business and not on the
technology not on the administration
like I connect with this guy that's an
awesome story I feel like he actually
carries about me where Microsoft might
be this big cold brand and the CEO is
never gonna talk to me but Neil can so
why can't it be you why are you what
this company why are you doing what
you're doing why are you passionate
about this business be Kramer and Jemma
SH have a face so a quick example this
is a series I do with Stephen Kelly he's
a CEO of sage they're a multi-billion
dollar company out of the UK every month
we get on a hangout together live on
YouTube we answer questions from my
audience
it's just 45 minutes to an hour of me
and him answering questions from the
audience never a sales pitch never
talking about how great sages just
providing value it's hard to see what
the numbers are between like a hundred
thirty and one hundred and fifteen
thousand views on those videos the
approval rating is like 93 to 97 percent
compared to like the 50%
Bank of America so people love him
people love him he's getting attention
he's getting traction he's being the
face and he's winning now people may not
need to buy counting software right away
there's never a hard call to action you
need to go buy sage immediately but
anybody who's watching who knows Stephen
Kelly who's seen all the valley has
provided if people are ready to buy
accounting software sage gets the first
default attempt right you're gonna go
there first they may not solve your
needs she goes somewhere else
but they get the first option because
you love Stephen Kelly because he's been
here and you as brands will get way more
value by doing these kinds of
collaborations with influencers than
spending all that money on a
professional film crew and actors and
lighting and stop motion graphics to
have 193 views on your video community
content Oh No we move on so content so
strategy is like where we're gonna plant
the fire right we've okay we're
selecting this spot now content we got
to build the fire we are start making
stuff starts with what are you staying
for what he was a brain staying for
understand that if you want people to
come to your channel your YouTube
channel your Twitter your Instagram
whatever it needs to be a feeling I want
to feel something what's the emotion
that you want people to feel when they
come to your channel that's important
that'll also make you proud by the way
of what you do it so you've got to
figure out what you stand for is a brand
my one word is believed so everything
that I do is believe it's always it's
always optimistic is always positive we
never show negativity on the channel and
people come back when they want more
believe what are you staying for what is
your brain stayin for so many companies
have this wall of their 13 core values
at their office where nobody knows what
the core values are like anybody here
who works at a brand I'll bet you the 10
bucks I gave Owen that you don't know
what your 13 core values are without
looking them up I bet your CEO doesn't
know what your 13 core values are
without looking them up so how is it
core to you and how you value it if you
have no idea what they are
so what is your brain staying for and
then we want to create content around it
this is Stephen Kelly the CEO of sage
that I work with
this is his LinkedIn I'm just trying to
show you different platforms so in
LinkedIn he's got almost 10,000
followers he's very positive he's
optimistic technology is amazing human
the human race is amazing everything is
going to be like let's go team human so
he brings that to his content so one is
the first one there is AI telling the
truth of a force for good so many people
are anti AI right like AI is gonna kill
the world the robots are coming for us
we're all gonna die and be their slaves
he's saying how great a AI is the next
one is look up look out look forward
challenging people to be positive to
dream big to go for it if you look at
the YouTube leaders we did we have
titles like carpe diem go seize a day
this is what sage and Stephen Kelly
staying for and it shows in his content
so if you need some positive optimistic
from a CEO you're gonna go to Stephen
Kelly that's what he stands for what are
you staying for and then bring that to
the work that you're doing because
that's the only way that you will stand
out and win you trying to be a copy
clone as somebody else is is his loss
his Owen here is he still here did he
step out Owen so Owens at the back we we
connected at a different event a couple
months ago and he was told me at a
little table that he was thinking of
ditching his his scream so at the
beginning of his videos let's hear it
Owen what do you got yeah yeah no no no
the scream the scream
he does that at the beginning of all his
videos and I love it like that vibe that
Owen you've seen him for the past couple
days that energy that's what--that's own
and you sitting at the tables like I'm
thinking about taking it out you know I
think I think I got to be a little more
professional my videos like no man you
suck a professional you lose a
professional don't be professional
I want the Owen video right that's how
you win that energy that charisma that
charm
that's how you win that's how you beat
all the other people who are doing the
same thing as you and so you need to
figure out what that thing is for you
and embrace it and expect people to
fight against it because you're standing
for something and when you stand for
something that means you stand against
something else so what are you staying
for and then bring that to your content
when I was at the airport on Wednesday
coming here I went to Twitter and I just
looked at what were the trending topics
right now on Twitter this is an
opportunity for you to make content
around what you stand for
so look at the look at what's trending
and then can you bring your voice to any
of these topics and this is something
that Jeremy vest challenged me on
he's like Evan you're all about believe
you're about positivity you should
comment on the news cycle like I don't
wanna comment on the news cycle it's
negative I don't want - I want evergreen
stuff I don't care about it he's like no
you you have a responsibility to bring a
positive voice to all the negativity out
there you got us bring believe to it
you're so right it sucks and it's the
best right you have a responsibility to
spread your mission through content so
some of these may be a little
controversial look the top four on
Wednesday we're Wednesday wisdom Michael
Kendricks Michael Jackson Dunn McGann
okay maybe you don't talk about dawn
McGann you know like maybe you don't
have anything to say you want to put
your brain in a dangerous spot I get it
but can you say something a Wednesday
wisdom can you add something in there
can you bring your brain messaging what
you staying for - Wednesday wisdom this
is how you start the win can you talk
about Michael Jackson maybe there's some
controversy there but net people like
Michael Jackson can you recognize his
creativity
can you recognize his thought leadership
can you recognize how he broke down
barriers and share that you have a duty
to share what you stand for and that's
how you're gonna get known next
community content so creating content
can be expensive I think a lot of people
spend money in wrong spots like the Bank
of America content we looked at but you
can use your community to help you 1
generate ideas and to get actual content
so we have 10,000 plus requests for
different videos to make from my
audience because we keep track of every
comment we reply to everybody don't turn
off your comments and they tell us what
they want now we don't just do what they
want it's got to be a mix what I want to
do with what the audience wants that's
how you win so you got 10,000 pieces of
feedback can you please make this
they're telling me I don't need them I
don't need to go hire some company to do
market research they're telling me what
they want now I get to pick and go make
it even if you're making three videos a
day take a long time to burn through
10,000 requests the other thing is
people are already talking about you
people especially the brands people are
talking about your brains already so I
was at the airport I type in Starbucks I
find Nicky Lorraine Co 1,600 followers
post this picture of her posing with her
Starbucks cup in some field and then
that comment at the top is from
Starbucks and I'll read it up here hi
Nicky We Heart this photo and they're
sending you a DM about it please check
your Instagram inbox when you have a
moment thanks Starbucks reached out to
Nicky and says we love your picture can
we post it on our Instagram and she said
yes so this picture appeared on
Starbucks his Instagram account as a
repost from Nicky did they pay Nicky
anything probably not Nicky's probably
pump just to be featured on Starbucks
his Instagram just probably pimped anon
out saying I was on Starbucks his
Instagram check it out
and it's free content maybe you give a
gift card you know whatever but it's
free content and it's community driven
content because when you say you're
amazing it's one thing but when people
say you're amazing they believe it other
people will believe that message so
everybody brands especially
everybody should setup hashtags and
searches for their own name I use a tool
I think it's within two buddy that you
can subscribe to alerts so anytime
anybody mentions Evan Carmichael in a
video or playlist I get an email and I
go to every video and I like the video
usually usually positive but even was
negative I still leave a positive
comment like Evan Carmichael sucks
hey thanks to the love man appreciate it
it's good everybody gets a comment and
often I'm the only one who left the
comment on that video when I'm paying
attention because you want your
champions to support you so at a minimum
you want to be keeping track of if
people are talking about you and
supporting your champions but ideally
you're also doing some outreach and
saying hey we love this picture can we
reuse it let's go to Bank of America
this is this is a good one so you
couldn't make this you couldn't make
this up so I'm at the airport this was
17 hours after I got to the airport this
guy takes his beautiful picture of a
Bank of America branch like that's a
pretty cool picture this is just some
guy or girl 500 followers tu i KW r CH
but the caption is ridiculous there she
is the most ridiculously happy Bank I've
ever seen are you kidding me
that's amazing like when has anybody
ever said that a bank was ridiculously
happy right thank you very keen to be
all over this guy or girl right like at
least comment to say hey thank you so
much
but reposted with that caption because
the Bank of America says hey look at our
ridiculously happy branch nobody's gonna
buy it but T ykw arch said it so now
it's real so involve your community in
making your content last point here on
content is share your process tell me
what goes behind the scenes in making
what you do let me in make me feel like
it's a little more intimate
imagine the restaurant where you can see
the the window into the kitchen or the
bakery where it's like right up front at
street level and you see the person
taking the bread or the pretzels that
pulls you in do that for your business
tell me how you do the thing that you do
especially something that you're proud
of show me the best practices because
big brands are always looking to small
companies for innovation ideas and
creativity and speed but small companies
entrepreneurs we're looking up to the
big brands for best practices we're
building infrastructure on quicksand we
don't have to build a business but not
how to hire people how do you hire
somebody I don't know I've never done
that before you don't go to school for
that so we all mess up our first hires
and then if you have a small team how do
you go from five to ten the 50 to 100 I
don't know we try to learn from big
companies give us that content so here's
an example as a video Google put out how
we hire and they have three recruiters
just sitting in front of a Google logo
with ok lighting and they sit there and
they talk about how they hire this vide
has a million views 940 something
thousand my eyesight is not fantastic
900 something this video is like a fifth
of the cost or less of the Bank of
America video it's just three people
sitting in front of the logo with a
camera answering questions but we hire
and it has a million views why because
anybody who wants to go work at Google
cares about how they hire because they
want to get the job but entrepreneurs
will look up to Google to say I wonder
how Google hires maybe I can copy them
so share this content let people in on
your processes and the bar is so low
that's that's the beauty you don't have
to be good to win there's so little
content being put out about this kind of
stuff that it's easy to win you win by
default and then you can worry about
getting better and then we talk to
leverage so strategy is about where
we're gonna plant the fire content is
we're building our fire leverage now
we're like I want to pour gasoline on
that fire I want to make this fire blow
up explode so I make few minutes a day
how do we do it well a lot of it is
repurposing content if you put all this
effort
work into making amazing video content
think about how you can dice it up into
multiple videos so example if if Darrell
is talking about strategies for
companies with 10,000 subscribers or
less right the algorithm 10,000 Scabbers
or less he talked about that today great
if he talks about it again
in two weeks at a different event and
says something slightly different if he
answers a couple questions some small
creators these pieces are buried in the
long video right it's an hour keynote
with questions so you might want to
watch the whole thing and great you
learn from Darrel but Daryl can easily
pull those four or five clips together
all targeted towards small creators
10,000 subscribers or less and make a
new video and call it Derral Eve's
top advice for small creators in 2018 so
you're repurposing the content every
piece of content lives in multiple
locations the other thing is if you have
winning content don't be afraid to post
it again this works everywhere except
YouTube because YouTube they don't like
duplicate content but everywhere else
you can post the same thing that one
three weeks ago again as long as it's
evergreen if we're celebrating Michael
Jackson's birthday don't celebrate it
again in three weeks but the other stuff
so here's what I do with Instagram with
Instagram I had a post it was dream I
have a quote it perform decently like
okay and three weeks gonna post it again
exact same post did better the second
time around don't think that people have
seen every single post that you've ever
put up on these platforms if it won
three weeks ago chances are it's gonna
win again in three weeks as long as it's
evergreen kind of content and even if
they had seen it before and they
remember it
don't assume that it's not valuable
again right don't assume that they read
that message and then boom they got it
and they never need to see it again
so every week we take two posts so our
weekend spots we take two of our
best-performing posts from the past year
and we post it again
as long as we haven't made that post in
the past two weeks we post it again it's
your best content you've put so much
into it you know that it wins
don't let it sit on some feed for months
ago
nobody's scrolling back that far post it
again it's an easy way to scale use
creators so you know creators are on the
underpriced they underpriced themselves
we Enterprise ourselves it's a great
opportunity for creators to use other
creators is great opportunity for brains
to get more creators whatever budget
you're spending on video I would first
put it into creators because you don't
know how to make video so let the
creators do their thing the fastest way
to build a brand is to work with people
who already have your audience and get
them to recommend you that's the fastest
way to grow and so I'd be looking at who
can I partner with who's in my industry
how can I work with them how can we make
a deal and then get out of their way let
the Creator do their thing don't be so
worried about the messaging and how it
looks because you don't know how to make
video anyway right let the Creator share
their message that's how you're gonna
win so this is a deal I work with
Microsoft this is this is an example
where I wanted to get up and share my
store with Microsoft with my audience
cuz I think Bill Gates saved my company
I've never met the man but his story
saved my business it's what allowed me
to continue to be an entrepreneur so I
thought okay I love Microsoft I love the
Bill Gates story I want to share
strategies I learned from Microsoft so I
I made a live hangout and people came on
and asked me questions and I shared
strategies that I had learned when I
first had the idea to do it I pitched
Microsoft and he said no no we don't
want to talk about Bill Gates go gates
is gone people don't like him he's not
involved in a business anymore don't
talk about Bill Gates like you guys are
stupid like for entrepreneurs Bill Gates
is a legend like you you have one of the
most historic founders of all time and
you don't want to use his name like
unless is some agreement that says you
can never mention Bill Gates you should
be pushing Bill Gates hard
nobody knows Satya Nadella entrepreneurs
who you're targeting don't know who the
CEO of Microsoft is but they know Bill
Gates
you gotta leverage it hard and so part
of it for brains it's get out of the way
let the creators do their thing and for
creators stand up for yourself don't put
out a piece of content that you know is
gonna suck I don't want to make a video
that doesn't talk about boot gates it's
not gonna do as well it's not gonna help
us achieve our outcome I would also
challenge you creators to start
increasing your pricing whatever you
charge last time 30% up the next time
and 30% up the next time until you face
some real resistance and the biggest
part of all of that is feel you deserve
it that 30% bump up feel like you
deserve it I'm worthless I'm bringing
this brand insane value because if you
don't feel you deserve it you're gonna
knock back down to where you were and
stay where you are forever you got to
earn your respect and the last one I
want to talk about is outreach so
outreach now where we're reaching out to
two groups one our fans so people who
are fans of your of your brand of your
content go check them out every now and
then do some surprise and delight leave
a comment on their video say hi Surprise
them with something know brand does this
some creators do it but no brand like
the again the bar for entry is so low
it's so embarrassing lilo that if I'm a
fan of Starbucks and Starbucks comes to
my small channel and says anything I'm
freaking out
so do that so find your fans go check
out their content every now and then and
leave a positive comment to comment on
people who are in your industry and
start the siphon they're their audience
so if you're in the entrepreneur space
you want to cup you want to come to my
channel comment and siphon my audience
if you leave a great comment people say
oh who's this person with such a great
comment I'm gonna go check out your
channel and I might notice it and maybe
we do a collaboration together it's
social media you got to be social stop
treating that just like this megaphone
you have to have interactions if you
have no
built-in interactions with your team or
with your customers with your viewers if
the most interaction you have is half an
hour a week of responding the comments
you're gonna lose your not being social
enough this is an especially big hack
for brains
because you guys have verified what
creators would do to get verified
especially on Instagram that's the
hardest one I got rejected the first
time for Instagram verification and
finally got a led in the second time why
it's so important is one it gives you a
visual cue if you leave a comment from a
verified YouTube account you get a
little blue check and say who's this
this is account I'm gonna check them out
on Instagram you get the blue check and
even better if you leave a comment your
comment goes to the top of that post if
you go to a popular post and you leave
your two cents and you're a verified
Instagram account your comment goes
right to the top that's not a hack for
creators but it's a hacker brains like
you get this job at a brand you didn't
do anything to deserve the blue check
but you got it so use it and you should
be doing it every day so here's an
example this is a guy that Tim Schmoyer
put me on to who's a fan of my channel
story greenlight he's a pretty new
creator talks about storytelling on
YouTube if you learn how to tell better
stories he's a good guy to go check out
he's a small Channel mm something
subscribers and he made a video
launching a new course that he had and I
mean first off I feel for the guy
because launching the new course in
general is difficult but when you only
have two thousand something subscribers
he's probably not gonna sell a whole lot
it's just a little too soon to be
selling a course but I write to him good
luck with the new course this is part of
what I'll do like I'll always randomly
just go check out my fans and leave a
comment look at their video leave a
comment he writes back Haven I
appreciate that thank you man surprise
and delight and a last quick one is dm's
video DMS for Instagram and Twitter I
don't know why I can't do it on YouTube
it's a video platform you can't leave a
video reply but you can do it on
Instagram and Twitter so I try to
everybody who d-ends me they get at
least one video response from me
I want one personal connection and on
Twitter I'll respond to a bunch of
people with video DMS too so this person
Jonathan from France just sent me a
quick DM and say hey thank you I like
your videos nothing crazy
and I'll write back and say I'll make a
video and I'll say hey Jonathan thank
you for the love man I really appreciate
it
I just want to spend 8 and 1/2 seconds
to say that I really love your message
believe that's how I'll do it and then
eight and half seconds later you know I
press send and you get comments like
this how sweet I appreciate so much the
fact that you took your time to send me
a private message what a great man you
are I wish you all the best on and on
I'm not that great I'm not great he's
laughing he's laughing cuz they I want
people to tell me that I suck inside
joke but I'm not great I am NOT great
the bar for entry is too low that people
are massively surprised that they get a
video of DM from somebody is ridiculous
like that should be all of you it's this
this shouldn't be a surprise it's just
providing great service is that the
cornerstone of every single great
business so I would I would strongly
encourage you for your Instagram and
Twitter accounts to get on doing some
video responses sometimes it's even
faster than typing something up and it's
it's low there's no budget like I mean
I'm in my car my wife picked me up it's
dark
we're shaky as we're driving and it's
eight and a half seconds and the guy's
freaking out it's not that hard to make
your customers amazingly happy doesn't
take a lot of work the bar for entry is
insanely low and it's your chance to win
if you just got a little bit of hustle
in you so that's the process you guys
have the slides you can you can go
through them I want to just end back on
my top point where you've learned a lot
not just hopefully in this session but
over the course of these couple days
you're taking time out of your work to
be here away from your family to be here
hopefully have a notebook filled with
notes I see people still writing stuff
down it's still gonna come down to what
are you gonna do about it like take that
list pick one thing and go home tonight
and do something about it
I learned the new strategy is Lane still
here Lane Lane was up there he is Lane
and I were hacking strategies I go
thumbnails last night and I was up till
3:00 in the morning working on my
thumbnails and I put three variations up
to test and I got a keynote today and I
got lots of emails to get back to I got
lots of DMS to get back to and everybody
wants a piece and everyone wants to do
interviews but you still got to get
momentum to happen what I don't want you
guys to do is feel a bunch of energy
coming out of here and then go home and
lose momentum I don't want you to come
back one year from today in the exact
same spot today matters my goal every
day is to get up and make something that
my grandkids will want to see I want my
grandkids to see this presentation is it
worth seen I don't know we'll see do I
always make something great absolutely
not but if you got up every day with the
intention of I want to make something
that I want my grandkids to see your
life your channel your brain would be
unrecognizable one year from today than
where you are right now so I just want
to transfer some energy like I want you
to go home and do something today she's
soaking it in she's soaking it in touch
somebody and run for any TD jakes fans
out there I really want you to do
something because I want you to win
because you guys got talent and the
thing that frustrates me the most is
people with insane talent who struggle
I've seen so many talented people here
and I really want you to win and that's
gonna come from action I want to lead
you with the 595 rule and that is five
percent of your time planning
ninety-five percent of your time doing
too many people are planning you playing
and it's fun to plan listen I love
planning entrepreneurs we love planning
it's so exciting to see we're gonna go
it's awesome but you're spending too
much time thinking somebody asked me on
the way in what email service provider
is the best for doing newsletters for
youtubers it's like listen I use Aweber
it's a whole bunch it doesn't matter
pick one and go go 95 percent your time
has to be doing do the word
thinking strategizing none of this
counts as doing this is not doing this
is planning and strategy doing starts
tonight when you get out of this room so
I'm super pumped to see where you go if
you guys start doing something tweet me
up send me an Instagram DM and I might
give you a video message back thank you
for the lavas been amazing being here
and I'd love to get some questions
we've a microphone questions work I have
the only mic okay so we got a yell I
guess
yeah so notifications when somebody
mentions you is through to buddy I don't
know if there's any other tool that does
it I don't know if it's free or not I'm
on their highest paid account but you
can put in any keyword and it'll notify
you if they mention your name and listen
I would also if you guys have a business
business I would put in my clients names
too to say hey you got mention on this
YouTube channel Congrats hack stocks
they get verified on Instagram so
Instagram just opened up requests so you
can recur now submit yourself I had to
go through my agent every other platform
you could do yourself Instagram used to
be closed but now like two days ago just
opened up so you can apply what I would
do if I'm you they care so much about
they really want to just have certain
level people I guess in I would one get
verified everywhere else first
I don't think so I've never seen that I
mean I haven't tried I'm not I'm not the
verification expert on those things but
they want to make sure that like who you
see you are is who you are so I would go
for like your main one your name go for
YouTube and Twitter if you go for
inserting verification you don't have
the others you're probably gonna get
rejected that's the starting point then
they want to see media so like I would
hack my way to get into major media
publications like this like what do I
have ink magazine Forbes Inc 100 great
leadership speakers all that stuff like
get listed on those that's not that's
not that difficult to hack and get
featured on those things you find out
who writes the list and you you make
contact with them and do some themes and
friendships and help them with what
they're doing and you stay on their
radar and they help you not that I'm not
a great leadership speaker but okay what
else we got
yeah so building a team as you get
bigger absolutely here's the thing I
think you need to think about what you
want to build and that's gonna be
something huge
right like you want to have it you want
to have a huge team huge channel or or
not if you have smaller ambitions that's
okay but think of what you want to build
and then what's the first step so for me
I did everything myself I did everything
myself I was I feel like edited I
researched I script wrote everything and
then I realized in that process I hated
editing like that's the worst for me I'm
mad respect for editors but I hated it
like that's the first thing I need to
give up and so I hate spending money til
I make you money so as soon as I said
I'm making money from my channel the
first thing I did was hired a part-time
editor and that part-time editor let me
go from one video week to two or three
videos a week and then as we made more
money I hired them full-time and then
now we hired her husband and there's two
full-time and then we hired their friend
has our overflow because we're making
three videos a day so we need lots of
editing and so you start with doing
everything yourself but thinking where
are you going to win so I'm not gonna
win by having the best editing because
I'm not the best editor so I'm not gonna
try to do videos that need fantastic
editing I'm gonna win on what I'm good
at and then you scale up bit by bit like
the first person you hire should not
even be a full-time person look at
hiring somebody for a couple hours a
week because you're gonna mess up your
first hire anyway so might as well mess
up small I might as well mess up like
learning how to manage somebody and
treating them like a human and not just
a robot who has to take stuff off your
plate and caring about their leadership
and their growth in their development
we don't go to school learning how to be
a leader so you're gonna make mistakes
so start start now
hire somebody for a couple hours a week
and build up I'll come around but we're
gonna
so when I was by myself that I do did I
have to break away and focus just doing
like it isolation not doing anything
else yeah I still him that way so for me
I like doing different things on
different days maybe I'm a I'm a wacky
bird but go with me on how I do it and
you can see if it works he or not Monday
is my mentorship day all I did was meant
to my team mentor mentor mentor mentor
mentor invest into their growth and
development Tuesday is my youtube day
I'll film I'll look through the edits
that my team has done anything to grow
the channel Tuesday Wednesday is gonna
be project day so I get to pick whatever
project I want to work on at the time to
help grow Thursday's public-facing day
so that's interviews hangouts podcast
I'm naturally introverted which probably
doesn't come out it doesn't feel like it
but I am and so it takes me a while to
get warmed up and then Friday I do is my
CEO day where it's like big picture
stuff to grow the business I do it for
two reasons one I have a really hard
time switching tasks like people
generally have a hard time switching
tasks but for me it's ridiculous so I
can't go from an interview to writing a
book it just takes me too long so like
you know what forget that I'm just gonna
do one day focus all on my YouTube and
I'm gonna crush YouTube on Tuesday and
that's it the second thing is it also
gives you a timeline it's like I need to
get everything done for my youtube
channel on Tuesday I'm not touching
again for the next week so I need to
make sure that's insanely productive and
the third thing is I like to I like to
miss it like I'm not coming back to
YouTube until next Tuesday
it's like and then I start I'm like
Friday like I when we go through my
youtube stuff again I start to miss it
so I play games with myself that way
right
but maybe I'm a crazy chicken and that's
how I do things right like there's
something else that may work for you but
I still find like I need to super focus
down maybe it's entrepreneur ad D but I
think you need to match your your
ambitions match your actions to your
ambitions so what's in your schedule
what's in your calendar you're talking a
big game you have big ambitions what are
your actions if you look at your
calendar if I look at my calendar and
say Monday's this day and Tuesday
Wednesday third day is assigned if I did
that work what I accomplish my goals
yes awesome no I need to adjust my
schedule
it's just my actions Nick yeah yeah
so lumen how bad you're gonna mess up on
your first hire yeah okay so so first
when you're hiring you have to lead with
values values first who is nicknamed and
what are we staying for what is this
brained all about
so I lead with belief for anybody who
knows my content channels like heavily
on the belief side hopefully felt a
little bit of a fire in this
presentation so I say I'm looking for a
video editor who believes in
entrepreneurs and believe is about this
and that's the entire opening paragraph
and right there I'll lose a lot of
people awesome if you don't believe in
entrepreneurs and like my message I
don't care if you have the greatest
skills of all time you're not gonna like
working for me either so go find the
thing that you want to go and do and
there's others who will say holy cow
this is amazing and they'll work harder
to apply for you so I think at the
beginning of a hiring process people
look too much at skills and they're
important but values are more important
so you leave with the values the mission
what is nicknamed in here to do what do
I stand for where I believe in more than
anything else in the world right what's
the problem trying to solve boom
powerful that when you read it it's like
man if I saw that I'd be all over that
job then I give a skill testing question
somewhere in the job description my job
description is one big long ugly
paragraph poorly formatted no brakes
ugly because I need someone whose
attention to detail to save me from me
not being attention to detail
and in the middle somewhere will be in
your first line of your description or
your job whatever the job job response
tell me how many subscribers I have my
youtube channel 80% of people who apply
never respond to that question so if
they didn't spend time reading actually
reading the job description why am I
going to spend time in your application
and it's like put it in the first line
so you automatically you cut 80% of the
people who applied to your job because
even if that's five minutes reading each
resume that's a lot of your time it's
frustrating
then I hire people on a trial job I
don't care what your past work was I
want to know what can you do for me now
and I'll give them up to five hours paid
to make me something that I think will
take them two hours it should take two
hours to do this I'm gonna give you up
to five hours and if you take the full
five hours you're probably not in
because either you're incompetent or
you're milking me either way I don't
want you right sometimes people will say
they'll write to me say well if you tell
me your YouTube channel name I'll tell
you how many subscribers you have it's
like it's not that difficult right like
just go to youtube and do it so just a
little bit of creativity you kind of
need in an entrepreneurial business and
then I'll see the process that who did I
like working with what was the end
result and I'm looking for somebody who
does what I asked him to do but then
also does a little bit more it's like I
asked you to do this
so like Christina the my editor now she
gave me what I wanted like here's what
you asked me for but I thought like this
thing might be funky too like this is
how I would do it and that's what I'm
looking for I want the person who's
gonna stretch it beyond just being an
order-taker because for editing I'm not
gonna be the genius editor to tell you
how to edit right I need you I want I
see it as co-creation anybody on my team
we're co-creating stuff together I might
be the face but like you're super
involved in making this project happen
and so I'll work with eight ten twelve
twenty people on these trial projects of
five hours some people never finish the
project and listen if somebody it's paid
project if they milk me for the full
five hours that I paid whatever full
price and they leave and they never
write back to me awesome okay like I'm
not so concerned about losing the X
amount of dollars on it and then you end
up hiring for the right skills because
you don't want to hire somebody who's
just a good interviewer they did great
when you interviewed them one on one but
you that's not what you're hiring for
you're not hiring a communications
person you're hiring an editor they
might be the worst person of all time in
front of you they might sweat and throw
up all over your desk but they could be
the greatest editor for your business
right like hire for the right skills and
so I spend zero time doing job
interviews and all the time actually
doing the work and then from there
usually get somebody who's who's great
and we move forward where most people
how they hire is to go through this long
process you look through all of the
resumes they're all you know they all
have fluff in them you do what lots of
job interviews you finally think you
found somebody
haven't even worked with them yet but
you found the right person then you
bring them in and then you realize after
two weeks like this is not the person
but you don't want to fire them because
you have to go through that painful
process again it's better to stick with
this okay person who drives you nuts
because it's too painful to go through
that whole thing again so I think the
hiring process is broken that helps
alleviate a little bit the other thing I
would say is just you have to be
invested into their growth you have to
care about them as a human and want them
to grow if you just see them as this is
somebody that I'm gonna dish out my
responsibilities to like all finally
it's this person he would take all this
it'll be more work for you in the first
couple weeks because you have to train
them how to do it you have to do
everything you're already doing slower
to teach them how to do it and you have
to care about them and so ultimately the
best thing for them maybe even to leave
your company like their ambition is to
go be a Netflix documentary maker
awesome they're gonna be with you for
three years you're gonna help them
you're gonna help them go get that
Netflix documentary you're gonna push
them away when it's not the best
interest to stay here anymore and when
they feel that you care and you love
them that much and you're invested as a
leader they'll give you everything like
you got there they're there they're not
just their brain but their heart and
soul where I know where this challenging
because it feels overwhelming I'm doing
everything myself and I need somebody to
help me but you need to spend the time
with your people to help them grow and
want to and I think you'd be great dude
I think you'd be like a fantastic leader
you standing up look at that
[Music]
so I start by thinking what's my
ambition where are the people that that
I want to be with so YouTube is still my
number one because there's so many
people out there that I can still grow
and reach I mean I'm at 1.5 million subs
but it's nothing compared to what it
could be just in my priority the other
platforms are great I need to figure out
where can I match what I love doing with
where the audience is so medium or leave
in LinkedIn Lincoln's moving video now
but I don't want to sit there and write
long posts it's not my thing I'd much
rather make a video and so YouTube being
the number one video platform I'm gonna
go video I'm picking up my Instagram
heavy like we're doing six posts a day I
go live four times a week on Instagram
we didn't I GTV everything why I'm
curious I like the taste right like the
taste just to see do I like it can I I
love the idea of starting over I
secretly hope sometimes my youtube
channel goes to zero just so I can start
it over again and blow up again so I
like the I like the process of starting
over with Instagram but the real reason
why I'm so heavy on Instagram is on the
live you can bring people in YouTube
live you get a bunch of questions on the
side so I do that once a week
Instagram live you can bring callers in
with video and your picture and picture
like I'm helping people from all over
the world four times a week I didn't do
it today because I'm here but that feels
me up like all that one-on-one stuff is
awesome and so I want that to scale hard
I'm so looking at now how do I grow how
do i hack Instagram we did a bunch of
funky stuff that other people aren't
doing we could we could talk Instagram
strats for days - if you guys want but
it always starts with where is the
audience and what am i interested in I
get is a huge LinkedIn audience I don't
want to do that kind of work if it goes
all video then maybe I don't want to
write the long posts I want to write
medium posts and I'm not
I could hire somebody to like be my
ghostwriter and posted those places but
I still have so much room to grow and
what I'm doing right now I don't think
it's enough of a priority yeah
there you go
salad there you go and another local
Dallas matchmaking got some biz dev
happening what else
hey I respect them yeah
okay cool
[Music]
[Music]
are you okay so I don't think you should
be everywhere I think you should get the
accounts everywhere and I think she'd be
listening everywhere if you if you if
your goal right now is YouTube accounts
awesome
get the Twitter account take the name
for so nobody can squat on it and say
they own it and then you have to pay
$18,000 to get the name back and you're
listening because if anybody tweets you
or it mentions you like Bank of America
right hashtag you can at least respond
and say thank you but it's very reactive
you're not being proactive so get all
the accounts but then do one thing
well like I did I did LinkedIn well and
then at Facebook well and then I did
Twitter well in YouTube well and to do
those while I stopped doing the other
things well I don't do Twitter and
LinkedIn well anymore YouTube now I'm
doing Instagram well I'm doing YouTube
while doing Instagram well but I have a
team like there's 8 to 11 of us
depending on the projects who helped me
do a lot of the stuff I'm still very
involved like I'm Hanes on every day
with everything but especially in the
editing side in the creation and people
helping me I would not I would not say
your audience isn't there your audience
is on YouTube your audience is on
Instagram when I hear that the thing
that that I think of for me is like I'm
just not good enough I haven't figured
it out yet I'm not good enough right so
like the content you're putting out is
not good enough yet yet it could be I
think the fastest path to win for you is
actually Instagram Facebook is great but
doesn't very little organic reach so
it's hard to build anything significant
YouTube is the place to be long term
because you're building the brand and
content lives forever
like I get views from videos five years
ago my army of 5,000 public videos just
keeps growing and that keeps bringing in
more people but Instagram was the
fastest way to do it
the thing is with Instagram you have to
stay on that treadmill or you become
irrelevant so if I'm you I'll probably
start Instagram hack it figure out how
to be great at it tell an amazing
message and then start building some
attraction build up some some
monetization some revenue and then my
next will probably be you tube to build
long-term content yeah
yep so sages sages not just enterprise
sage says startup accounting software so
that's why he wants to work with me I
don't we don't talk enterprise at all my
owners would tune out super quick so
it's branding listen for anybody selling
brain deals to things this is this is
super important if you want to make
money doing brand deals one don't do one
offs every brand deal that I do is a
year-long plus deal sage is a three-year
long deal because it takes one so much
effort for you to get to know the client
to work with their stuff and I actually
use the stuff like sage is my accounting
software provider I don't I want to be
able to talk to you guys about if you
come up and say hey can you look at my
balance sheet we can go through it so
annual deals and actually use the stuff
what I would still look at I mean if you
have zero brand deals then then I would
even do one for free whatever just to
have a demo example but I'd be looking
at how do I turn this into an annual
deal quickly because they're very rarely
gonna get an ROI off of the first video
you have to figure out what works what
doesn't work and the second thing is I
don't want to be in the direct marketing
business I'm in the brain building
business don't come to me and and make
me click off to your newsletter or your
coupon code you're giving them way more
value than just the direct marketing if
you're in the direct marketing business
you are losing you need to think of
yourself more as brand building when the
when the New York Yankees are sponsored
by coca-cola New York Yankees aren't
giving coca-cola monthly reports and how
many people are coming through their
turnstiles
and took their coupon code when they sat
down on their seat but that's the
mindset like I want you to think of
yourself as the New York Yankees for
your industry
you want to work with entrepreneurs I'm
one of the best in the world to work
with I'm the you I'm the New York
Yankees if you don't respect yourself
like that there's no way they will but
if so it's like with sage we do some
reports but it's not it's never like oh
this video it's more for like how do we
make it better but there's no call to
action that we track there's no landing
page that hey guess if Evan Carmichael
that we lead into some funnel any brain
that wants to do that does not
understand the value of branding I am
not in direct marketing business you're
given you're giving up way too much
value if you be in the direct marketing
business my getting kicked off no
questions listen a bunch you guys have
come up to me like in the hallways and
said hey I want to take a picture I want
to ask you a question but I was afraid
during these past couple days like this
is your chance like if you got a
question something's in your head raise
your hand because I want to answer it to
give you value like you paid to be here
with spending time I want to help you
let's go with the hat
well you both have hats cowboy hat okay
okay
yeah let's do it that's quick yeah okay
okay yeah so so that this is when you're
confident you can provide the value
right like if you've never done a brand
deal do one even if it's for free get
get like I would do it for free if they
would put it to the newsletter list so
you have a sample but if you know you're
bringing value like I bring sage tons of
value if you're bringing lots of value
you're confident what you're doing then
stop taking on these one-off deals and
even now like if they got value after
that one for 500 bucks look at how do i
how do i in my demo in my first one how
do i just give them fifty thousand
dollars worth of value like this is
insane how much value they want to work
with you forever
and then the next conversation is okay
how do we turn this into an annual deal
and it's a video every two months you
video every month like you work it out
you should do one a month with clients
but whatever fits your production
schedule cool hope you guys enjoyed the
keynote let me know your comments down
below if you want to see what I did here
yesterday go check out the video next to
me much love there's simple tasks right
but it ends up being a real life part
like a growth process who's gonna push
you you push yourself